الضفه الغربيه قتلت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فلسطينيا واصابت اخر بالقرب من
تجمع مستوطنات غوش سيون شمال الخليل
وافادت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بان سياره
كان داخلها مسلحان فلسطينيان اقتحمت حاجز
مستوطنه متسادا العسكري واطلق النار فردت
قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي باطلاق النار
عليهما تفاصيل معك منتصر نصال نرحب بك من
الخليل
تفضل نعم محمد بالفعل تطورات متلاحقه في
الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه حسب اخر
المعلومات الوارده نحن نتحدث عن قيام جنود
الاحتلال باطلاق النار على شابين وصلاه
الى مستوطنه
متسادا وهي تقع ضمن المجمع الاستيطاني
التابع لجوش عتسيون شمال مدينه الخليل حسب
المعلومات المتوفره بان جنود الاحتلال
اطلقوا النار على هذين الشابين بذري انهما
قاما باطلاق النار عند مدخل هذه المستوطنه
وقوات الاحتلال قالت في بيان لها وبررت
ذلك بانهما حاولا اطلاق النار واطلقت
النار باتجاهه ما الاعلام العبري تحدث عن
استشهاد احد هؤلاء الشبان واصابه اخر قبل
دقائق من خروجنا على الهواء معكم كنا على
التواصل مع العائله حتى هذه اللحظه
العائله لا يوجد لديها اي معلومات متعلقه
بمصير ابنائها وحتى اللحظه لم يستطع اي
اسعاف فلسطيني من الوصول الى تلك المنطقه
الواقعه ضمن ما تعرف ببريه سعير هذه
المستوطنه مستوطنه مساده تقع على اراضي
المواطنين في بلده سعير شمال شرق الخليل
ومنعت قوات الاحتلال الاسعاف الفلسطيني من
الوصول الى المكان وكانت اصلا فتشت
مركبتين اسعاف عند منطقه دوار بيت عنون
وقامت باخذ مفاتيح مركبات الاسعاف من
سائقي الاسعاف وقامت بتفتيشها تفتيشا
دقيقا وعطلت وصولها
الى موقع الحدث في تلك المنطقه وكما ذكرنا
المعلومات نستقي من الاعلام العبري حول
مصير الشابين الحديث عن شهيد واصابه اخر
والعائله لا يوجد لديه اي معلومات متعلقه
حول مصير ابنائها في الضفه الغربيه
الموضوع لا يقتصر محمد فقط على الخليل
هناك شهيد اخر ايضا في مخيم عين السلطان
في اريحا في منطقه غور الاردن قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت مخيم عين السلطان واندلعت
مواجهات بين شبان فلسطينين وقوات الاحتلال
هذه المواجهات اسفرت عن استشهاد شاب وعن
اصابه سيده ستينيه بحاله اختناق جراء قيام
قوات الاحتلال اطلاق قنابل الغاز السامه
المسيل للدموع خلال اقتحام مخيم عين
السلطان بارتقاء هذين الشهيدين نحن نتحدث
بحسب اخر الاحصائيات لدى وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه منذ السابع من اكتوبر في الضفه
الغربيه الحديث يدور عن 350 شهيدا 30 من
هؤلاء الشهداء فقط ارتقوا منذ بدايه العام
الحالي 2 24 ونحن نتحدث هنا عن الضفه
الغربيه ما بعد السابع من اكتوبر التصعيد
متواصل طبعا اشير ايضا الى ان قبل قليل
مواجهات اندلعت بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال
في بلده دير سامت غرب دوره جنوب محافظه
الخليل هذه المواجهات ادت الى اصابه طفل
يبلغ من العمر 11 عاما حسب شهود العيان
هذا الطفل كان متواجدا بجانب الطريق قوات
الاحتلال داهمت المنطقه اطلقت الرصاص بشكل
مباشر على هذا الطفل الذي يبلغ من العمر
11 عاما تم نقله الى احد المستوصفات
الطبيه في بلده دير سامت جنوب الخليل وقدم
له العلاج طبعا ما يجري في دير سمت ياتي
في اطار استكمال ما تقوم به قوات الاحتلال
من فرض طوق امني على تلك المناطق دير سمت
بتعوه وغيرها من المناطق التي وضعت سواتر
ترابيه منذ يوم امس على هذه المناطق
وعزلتها بشكل كامل واستولت على منازل في
المنطقه وحولتها الى ثكنه عسكريه هذه
التطورات المتلاحقه تاتي بعد عمليه اطلاق
نار وقعت السبت في مستوطنه ادورا غرب
الخليل اسفرت عن استشهاد ثلاثه شبان هم
ابناء عموما من عائله ابو جحيشه في بلده
اذنا غرب الخليل ومنذ ذلك الحين محمد قوات
الاحتلال تشدد من اغلاقات على مدينه
الخليل تغلق كافه المداخل المؤديه الى
المدينه وتشدد من اجراءاتها الامنيه وطوق
الامني الشامل في الخليل جنوب الضفه
الغربيه تصل نصم من الخليل شكرا جزيلا لك